you forgot you got bit by a pig
there's been a lot I was in Seattle
doing shows my buddy was like oh my
friend has a farm you can go there and
shoot some stuff so I go to this pig
farm shooting stuff with a pig I'm like
you know whatever you shoot with a pig
I'm banging it no um I uh I don't
remember you know I was feeding the pig
I was just having some fun with the pig
so I'm like feeding the pig and uh and I
just push it one feed too far this tooth
goes into my hand I can't remember where
it was right here I don't know if a pig
tooth Mark in your hand there should be
really should be I recoil cuz I'm like
what the you know a pig bit me I
hope nobody knows and it just starts
gushing what's the farmer saying yeah
the pig bites this never H has never
happened never heard of it happening
okay you know they're looking at me like
what an idiot do you fingered the pig
but when I flew the next day it I swear
to God it looked like a pig hoof it blew
up like I was like and will I be Pigman
like I was expect like